[Music]
in our previous video we listed out few
of the situations that we may come
across in our lives where we have to
estimate the numbers we mostly estimate
numbers by rounding them off now I want
you to understand something really well
estimation solely depends on one thing
it depends on the number which is being
estimated it depends on what the number
represents for example let's say we want
to round off number 74 what is the best
approximation or estimation of the
number 74 that you can think of is it 70
or 100 the answer depends on what 74
represents in the real world say the 74
represents the number of students
present in your class on any regular day
say a monday here 70 is a good
estimation of 74
however 100 is not quite a good
estimation here there can't be that many
students in a class so we can say that
around 70 students were present on
Monday so in this situation 70 is a
reasonably fair approximation of the
number 74 but let me give you another
situation here say the number 74
represents the price of any commodity
excluding taxes if this is the case that
it is fair to assume the actual price of
that commodity to be around 100 rupees
with all the taxes included so in this
case 100 is a better estimation of 74 so
the estimation of any number solely
depends on what that number is
representing in the real world depending
on what that number is representing we
can estimate the numbers in different
ways estimating to the nearest ten by
rounding off or estimating to the
nearest 100 or thousand by rounding off
and so on let's look at the first case
that is estimating the numbers by
rounding them off to the nearest ten
what do you mean by the nearest ten
nearest ten here means nearest multiples
of ten what are the multiples of ten 10
20 30 90 100 110 200
Burnie and so on okay let us understand
this with the help of an example let's
round off the number forty nine to the
nearest ten what is the multiple of ten
which is nearest to forty nine
yes it's fifty so we can say that fifty
is a good estimation of forty nine to
the nearest ten what about 48 which
multiples of ten is nearest to forty
eight it's fifty again similarly fifty
is a round figure of forty seven as well
as forty six to the nearest ten
what about forty one is fifty here the
best estimation for forty one to the
nearest ten not really if we are talking
about the nearest multiple of ten then
forty is much nearer to 40 150 so 40 is
the best estimation of forty one as the
nearest multiple of ten forty is also
the best estimation of 42 43 and 44 as
you can see only number remaining in the
40's is 45 what about it which multiple
of ten is near to this number forty or
fifty well we see that both forty and
fifty are equidistant from forty-five
however by convention becomes dove fifty
that is the higher multiple of ten to be
the estimation of forty five to the
nearest ten okay now here is a question
for you to answer round off these three
numbers to the nearest ten best of luck
well the nearest multiple of ten to the
number twelve is ten that's right so
twelve is rounded down to ten what about
eighty nine should it be rounded to
eighty or ninety the nearest multiple of
ten to the number eighty nine is ninety
and 225 225 is equally close to two
hundred and thirty as it is to 220 by
convention we take the round figure of
225 as 230 let's consider a few bigger
numbers now
estimation of 428 is 430 and that of
five thousand six hundred and eighty six
is five thousand six hundred and ninety
here are a few questions I will leave
for you to solve tell us the answers in
the comment section below
you